edie chief speechwriter for President
Bill Clinton recalls Franklin
Roosevelt's confrontation with the US
Supreme Court who objected to vital
elements of his New Deal legislation the
New York Historical Society is the host
of this event it lasts about an hour
greetings fellow deadheads
so your favorite album is what now I
want to hello everyone it's great to be
here with my pal Jeff sazzle and his
terrific book I mean like really great
book and you know timing is everything
in life I mean I I'm gonna not talk a
lot but I want to tell one little story
when I went to I went to college with a
woman who later went to work for The
Wall Street Journal and then as far as
we could tell like disappeared from the
face of the earth and she was supposedly
writing this book and no one no one had
heard from her knowing what no one knew
what she was going to do you know
whether this book was ever gonna come
back years passed years passed finally
in the spring of 1990 this book comes
out the book comes out the week Anita
Hill testifies before the the Senate
Judiciary Committee and my friend was
Susan Faludi in the book was backlash
so sometimes timing works out well and I
thought of that with supreme power
because just for Jeff's benefit John
Roberts decided to get into a nasty
fight with Barack Obama but then the
Congress decided to fast a potentially
controversial II involved major piece of
legislation which may wind up before the
Supreme Court all for your benefit
Jeffrey thank you fabulous my publicist
and I work this out very carefully
WW Norton runs the world okay like your
last book mutual contempt the
sensational book about the relationship
between RFK and LBJ really just a
wonderful book and anyone interested in
that period Jeff's book is one of the
first that made great use of the White
House tapes so you know you have these
people in real time talking about the
issues that are subject to the book you
turn several years later to the court
packing crisis of the mid 30s why well I
speak specifically about the court pack
crisis in a minute but I clearly am
drawn to stories of conflict and this is
really one of the great conflicts of the
20th century it's really the greatest
constitutional crisis are we getting a
little ringing in the sound system is
anybody hearing that or is that just a
sign on a little bit they have I been to
too many dead concerts are we okay on
the sound is everybody okay okay I'm
sorry go ahead and there are no colors
swirling yeah so I I think I'm drawn to
narratives of conflict because in the
clash between Titans of one kind or
another whether it's LBJ or RFK or
whether it's FDR in the Supreme Court
fundamental issues are really brought to
the fore and these two institutions
these individuals in this book and in
the last one are really fighting for
great stakes okay so let's talk about
the the plot of supreme power set the
stage 1935 what's happening with regard
to FDR in the New Deal and how is the
Supreme Court involved well 1935 the
Supreme Court starts to essentially
declare the New Deal to be against the
law or against the Constitution it
begins in earnest to strike down not
just New Deal programs there are a lot
of New Deal programs but the
centerpieces of the New Deal it begins
with the National Recovery
administration the Recovery Act the NRA
and then it moves on to the triple-a the
Agricultural Adjustment Act the farm
program and other central pillars of the
new dealers are knocked down in short
succession usually but not always by a
very narrow margin five to four and so
there's a very real question by 1936
whether Roosevelt can actually get
anything fundamental done in the country
because the Supreme Court is standing in
the way of everything not just in the
way the federal government but in the
way of the states because states
meanwhile are passing laws trying to
implement minimum wages and all sorts of
things set maximum hours for certain
kinds of jobs and the court begins to
strike in earnest these sorts of pieces
of legislation down to so as justice
don't put it at the time the court
seemed to have tied Uncle Sam up in a
heart
not and it wasn't clear how he or we
were gonna get out now even though no
one in this audience is nearly old
enough to remember anything about
Franklin Roosevelt
I think he's familiar to figure to many
of us here talk about who was on the
Supreme Court at this time who were they
and just characterized the court at this
moment well this was the oldest court in
American history and this is something
that people were aware of they were
known popularly as the nine old men and
the oldest was Brandeis but there were
many others who were nearly as old as
Brandeis and the the court was had been
pretty reliably but not consistently
conservative for a number of decades by
this point that really for many decades
and there was a clear sense from the
time the Roosevelt was elected in
November 1932 that there was going to be
a confrontation between FDR and this
court it's not simply that they were old
but that many of them not including
Brandeis but but many of the older
justices were really 19th century men in
spirit you had Willis Van Deventer who
was old enough to actually remember as a
boy watching Lincoln's funeral
procession Charles Evans Hughes who was
the Chief Justice at this time and had
been on the court previously in 1910
Charles Evans Hughes when he was a
student at Brown University not only had
no running water or central electricity
it in his dorm but he had two closets
one for his stuff and the other for the
call that he would use to shovel into
his into his heater so I and my favorite
perhaps the worst human being ever to
serve on the Supreme Court James
McReynolds who the story goes with such
an appalling anti-semite that used to
get up and leave the conference room
when Brandeis or Cardozo would speak but
not only that but when Cardozo was
inducted as a Justice McReynolds was
forced to sit through that ceremony so
he pulled out a newspaper and rustled it
very loudly throughout the induction
ceremony and and and he got confirmed
stuff
so that's that's the core and who was
the chief justice the Chief Justice was
Charles Evans Hughes and I'll say
something about him in a second but I
think just to go back to your last
question the other thing to know about
this court was that they didn't use the
term at the time but to use a term of
ours it was a very activist court and
between 1933 and 1936 it was overturning
federal laws at ten times its previous
rate and so this was a court on a
mission and it really did the
conservative justices really did see it
as a mission a holy war on some of their
supporters set against communism in
Anarchy which they saw communism at
least in the New Deal and you know
without descending too far into legal
geekdom what was the rationale for what
was the legal reason that all these New
Deal laws were unconstitutional well
there were a lot of different doctrines
and clauses and vote from the Commerce
Clause to the contracts clause and the
doctrine of substantive due process and
a whole range of other things that were
used to strike down these programs many
old doctrines were revived for the task
and so forth but really fundamentally
this notion the Conservatives notion of
constitutionality was rooted in the 19th
century in the lezzy Fair doctrines of
the late 19th century and of the sense
of constitutionality as implying a few
things a limited government states
rights and a constitution of limitations
it was not as Roosevelt felt a broad
Avenue through which a lot of things
could pass and get done it was a
constitution of limitations and
sometimes sometimes as one of the
justices said those limitations pinch
now one of the questions that often
comes up with Supreme Court justices
it's certainly a question that I have
thought about a lot in terms of the
period I wrote about is how much are the
justices applying principles and letting
the chips fall where they may
and how much are the justices finding
legal principles to accommodate a
political result that they want to reach
well and and so as you
get to the this critical New Deal period
and period of conflict how does that
trade-off look to you well certainly
there were a lot of precedents that
could be and were applied to strike down
social legislation whether it was before
Roosevelt or particularly during
Roosevelt's presidency there was no
shortage of opportunities for the
Conservatives to do that but there were
also very many opportunities for them to
sustain a lot of this legislation there
were other precedents that they could
have called upon as well so both options
were really there in front of the court
and what you see during this period and
I alluded to this a moment ago is you
see the justices scrambling in some
cases for doctrines that have been out
of favor for for decades that everybody
thought had sort of declared dead
decades before and suddenly they're
applying them with vigor to these new
deal cases were applying two of them to
the same new deal case when they could
have decided it on narrow grounds
they're deciding on the most sweeping
grounds possible so that they are
essentially preemptively declaring any
legislation of this kind
unconstitutional
FDR obviously the protagonist of your
book in many respects the protagonist of
the period talk about his attitude
towards the court I mean you know he
says he is one of the obviously great
figures in American history but talk
about how he looked at the court as a
political institution as a legal
institution and as the conflict between
the him and the court grew well he saw
the court as a political institution and
that probably won't surprise anybody
here but when Roosevelt in the 1932
campaign gave a campaign speech I opened
the book with this it's chapter one he
goes to Baltimore in October 1932 and
he's he's campaigning against not only
Hoover but against the Republican rule
generally and he says the Republicans
have controlled the White House they
have controlled the Congress and for
good measure they also have control of
the Supreme Court that would seem a
fairly uncontroversial statement today
but it was explosive at the time or at
least the Republicans tried to make it
explosive shocked that he would imply
that the Supreme Court was in politics
there still was this shocking and there
still was this notion very strong then
still exists today but not quite at this
level that that when someone put on the
judicial robes that he parted with his
politics he might take an idle interest
in politics like following the pennant
race in baseball but they were above
this sort of thing they weren't
interested or engaged Roosevelt never
bought that and one of the first things
that he asked his new Attorney General
Homer Cummings to do when he got into
office was to figure out how many of the
appointees how many of the judges on the
federal bench at all levels had been
appointed by Republicans and how many by
Democrats and there were only 20 28
percent of federal judges were Democrats
by affiliation and so they felt that
they had a big partisan problem on the
federal bench and Roosevelt didn't think
fundamentally this was about the
Constitution he thought it was about
special interests and politics so all
through his first term he has these
problems with the law is getting
overturned when does the idea start to
percolate to do something about the
court itself well interestingly for the
first time before he's inaugurated he's
aware that there's going to be a
confrontation with this court there's
talk in the press about an inevitable if
Roosevelt keeps half of his campaign
promises there's going to be a
confrontation and so one of his key
supporters an incoming senator from
California actually sits down with the
incoming Attorney General and says what
are we going to do about the court what
are we going to do about the old fossils
on the court as he put it and he floated
an idea that they would pass a
constitutional amendment to relegate any
justice past the age of 72 to emeritus
status just sort of push them aside and
so this is beginning to circulate and
starts to circulate in the press even
before very many New Deal programs have
passed so the notion of doing something
to the older justices is in the air
in the early in the first term now one
of the curiosities about the Supreme
Court that a lot of people don't realize
is that the number of justices is not
established in the Constitution that
there's nothing in the Constitution that
says there's nine and that is a creation
of Congress by law talk a little about
that concept because I again I think you
as you said people are surprised by that
it's an amazing thing actually to
consider most people don't really think
of it this way but tomorrow the Congress
could decide to increase the number of
justices to seventeen and there's
nothing in that in the Constitution to
suggest that it can't do so on the
founders left the number deliberately an
open question and in 1789 the number of
justices was set at six and it went up
and down over the course of the 19th
century sometimes for reasons of
efficiency sometimes as the business of
the country increased you needed more
justices but usually it was a matter of
politics and there were a series of
presidents of beginning with Madison and
running all the way through Jackson who
kept coming to Congress and saying I
want more justices they wanted more of
their own appointees on the court and
actually in 1866 Congress eliminated two
seats on the Supreme Court just to deny
Andrew Johnson the chance to appoint
anybody which it's an extraordinary
story and and it was really only under
President Grant that it went to nine and
his and has remained ever since so when
does court packing become more of go
from a jazz conversation with one
senator to something like a real
proposal well it's it's an idea that
never really establishes much momentum
it's in the air from the beginning as I
suggested and one of the things that I
wanted to do in this book was to try to
track when the idea first begins to
emerge in public discussion when
Roosevelt starts to get letters
suggesting it and so forth and it really
does happen right away but it is very
much a fringe idea it comes up and
usually when it comes up someone says
but of course he could do this but if
course you wouldn't do this it's an
outrageous idea it's a terrible
appalling idea and that's what most of
Roosevelt's advisors said so most of the
discussion throughout Roosevelt's first
term is not about packing the court it's
about amending the Constitution and in
1936 when things really come to a head
there were 100 separate constitutional
amendments proposed in Congress to deal
with the Supreme Court either to strip
away the right of judicial review
altogether which essentially I'm not
sure what's left of the court if you do
that to strip the courts review of
social and economic legislation so that
it just can't even consider these
questions or to allow the Congress this
was a very popular proposal to allow the
Congress to overrule the court by a
two-thirds vote it could just overturn
any Supreme Court decision these were
very much in the air a constant topic
that the the the country and Washington
in particular in 1936 were like a
rolling Constitutional Convention this
was a national discussion a national
debate radio programs constant coverage
in the press and so there is the sense
by the time Roosevelt wins his landslide
reelection that November this
something's going to happen that he's
got to do something about the court and
almost surely it's gonna be a
constitutional amendment and and how
does that evolve into the actual
proposal well Roosevelt over this period
as everybody seems to be getting higher
and higher on the idea of amending the
Constitution
Roosevelt's hours on it for a couple
reasons one was purely pragmatic and
political he just felt that it was going
to take too long and would be too hard
to amend the Constitution you have to go
through all the state legislatures it's
just very cumbersome process okay that's
one reason so 13 states could decide
it's not happening and it's not
happening so there was a practical
argument but fundamentally Roosevelt
didn't think there was any contradiction
between the Constitution and the New
Deal
he thought the problem was not the
Constitution the problem was this group
of justices particularly the five who
were constantly voting against New Deal
programs so his focus became a how do we
do something quick and expedient that
will solve the problem and be how do we
do it without
disrupting the fabric of the
Constitution there's nothing wrong with
it and there's nothing in the
Constitution that should stand in the
way of what you know the New Deal was
meant to accomplish so he comes back to
this idea that's been in the air all
along but it's been dismissed all along
and that is packing the court and and
how what I mean it's funny court packing
is that's how it's described but a lot
of people I think don't know what the
actual proposal was what went how was it
made public when was it made public and
what was it I mean what was Roosevelt's
proposal for about the court well I'll
start with the last question the
proposal which Roosevelt thought was was
very clever and it took them a while he
at Roosevelt and his Attorney General to
arrive at this particular by device they
knew they wanted to expand the size of
the Supreme Court so they could
essentially outnumber the conservatives
they had given up on the idea trying to
force the Conservatives off the court so
what do you do you outnumber them with
liberals but they they got stuck for a
while on what kind of principle they
could hang this on so they went back to
the very beginning and this question of
age and their argument was that for any
justice who had passed a certain age in
this case it was 70 or 70 and a half
that they would be that the president if
they refused to resign at that age
refused to retire then the president
would have the right to appoint an
additional justice to essentially sit
beside that justice and join him on the
court and so what this what would have
happened in 1937 if Roosevelt had got
what he asked for is and if none of the
six who were over that age had resigned
he would have gotten to appoint six new
justices overnight now he's only been 15
there would have been 15 and they said
uh there was much debate about this but
they set a limit at 15 and even if all 9
or 80 years old he had only it could
only reach a ceiling of 15 and and so
this was part of the problem with the
plan well there were many problems with
the plan politically and one is as you
suggested a while ago that the number of
9 had been reached in 1869 and
no one remembered that it had ever been
anything like that anything other than
that and so there was the sense that it
was sacrosanct in some way the number
nine but there was also the feeling that
this was an insult to all people and
that you had these great distinguished
jurists the most distinguished in the
view of liberals was Brandeis it was the
oldest member of the court and so and
and then you had the added problem of
the fact that Roosevelt couched the plan
in an argument that it wasn't about
ideology at all it was about efficiency
and he sort of implied that these older
justices were falling behind in their
work and this was true across the
federal bench and so what we needed was
more judges at every level and so but
this didn't really fool anyone and I
think how was the public what was the
public read when did when did the
proposal when was it made public in 37
February 5th so so even right after the
weeks after his you know that was the
first inauguration in January right
because he was yes March in 33 so he's
inaugurated in January 20th he proposes
this two weeks later a month yeah
actually two weeks later what's what's
the public reaction well just take a
half a step back there is as I said
earlier the sense that Roosevelt's going
to do something about the court and it's
only a matter of when but he hasn't been
talking about it publicly and so there
there's a general sense both in the
Congress and in the country that this
isn't going to happen immediately but it
will happen soon people in the Congress
are waiting for some kind of signal from
the president what what he's going to do
but they sort of feel many of them feel
that they can't wait for Roosevelt and
they try to get ahead of him and in the
first 10 days of the congressional
session in 1937 there are 50 proposals
to curb the Supreme Court so there was a
lot of activity and Roosevelt felt that
he had to step up his timetable
so that Congress didn't get much farther
than he had he has Roosevelt kept his
plans with
with respect to the court a secret even
from most of his inner circle it was
really developed after four years of
very wide-ranging and open conversation
with all sorts of experts and advisors
and members of the government he
essentially shut the process down in the
fall of 1936 and went into a bit of a
huddle with his Attorney General home
Homer Cummings and the the plan was put
together in pieces within the Justice
Department so that Cummings assistants
didn't really know what they were
working on he told them all the the same
thing you're working on a project of
great importance and what it added up to
they didn't know so the plan when
Roosevelt unveiled it at the beginning
of February was a huge shock to the
nation to the Congress which he had not
consulted to his cabinet whom he had not
consulted and again this is one of the
real eye Roosevelt felt that this
element of surprise would would be part
of the would be instrumental to the
success of the plan that he would
surprise his enemies and get this
through very quickly and instead it
became one of the the biggest problems
that he faced was lack of consultation
how was their support for I mean talk
about how the the the the it was a huge
landslide in thirty-six overwhelming
Democratic majorities in the House and
Senate did the Democrats support him on
it well some of the Democrats supported
him on it but a good number didn't and
the progressives in the party and and a
number of liberals actually abandoned
him among us a sufficient number for a
range of reasons there were a number of
progressives that progressives and in
that period were kind of iconoclasts and
most of them were loners within the
Senate and they had been leaders and had
if some name to men like hyerin johnson
of california who would run on the bull
moose ticket with teddy roosevelt in
1912 who had been governor a reformist
governor of california and by this point
he had wanted two things Hiram Johnson
he had wanted to be president and he had
wanted to be a Supreme Court justice and
by 1937 it was clear that neither
neither of these things
what's gonna happen and he was old and
ill and embittered terribly embedded at
Roosevelt who he thought was showing
dictatorial tendencies you had Bert
wheeler a Montana Democrat another
leading progressive who had actually
split from the Democrats in 24 to run
with LaFollette on the progressive
ticket and then came back and and
wheeler was a real fighter and it
actually been for Roosevelt sort of
publicly but I had his suspicions about
Roosevelt in 1932 and almost immediately
became very personally embittered toward
Roosevelt so you have a number of these
progressives who have personal grudges
against the president and ideological
concerns that there's too much power
being centralized in Washington and then
you had Liberal Democrats who worried
that if a court became more of a
political extension of the White House
this was their fear then civil liberties
would be very much in danger and the
court had had actually been a real
champion of civil liberties even as it
was conservative on economic questions
it had been really championing a free
speech and other civil liberties over
the course of the 1920s in particular
and so there was the feeling on the part
of a lot of liberals and liberal groups
Catholics and and and others that there
was a lot to lose if the Supreme Court
not due to Roosevelt appointees but the
next president's appointees if he
happened to be a conservative to me what
I thought the most dramatic part of your
book was the machinations in response in
the court itself because they were
simultaneously the focus of this
controversy yet not technically allowed
to speak out under the rules of decorum
and then in effect how did the justices
respond well they were even Cardozo was
opposed to and he was Roosevelt's
strongest supporter on the court and
Brandeis was a supporter of the New Deal
for the most he was he was a supporter
of the New Deal but he actually thought
that the nrn the Triple A were sort of a
disaster in certain ways and so even as
he was deeply involved with many members
of the administration and
and mentors mentor to many of them he
had his suspicions about the New Deal
and its centralization of power as he
saw it but they were all strongly
opposed as you might imagine to the idea
of packing the court they thought that
it would do great damage to the
institution of the Supreme Court that
there could be no respect in the Supreme
Court once it became such a political
football and some of them talked among
themselves about resigning if the court
packing plan passed at least a couple of
them probably would have and you see
them to your question the during this
period they're really chafing at the the
constraints of being Supreme Court
justices and not being able to say
anything publicly and so this this
starts to break down a little bit
McReynolds who you mentioned the the
most extreme conservative on the court
gives a public speech tis fraternity
brothers and talks a lot about
sportsmanship
what's we're being surprised what school
it was I think it was Vanderbilt all
right I look at my own index anyway
that's our I mean to put you in the spot
and so McReynolds speaks out and there's
a little tempest about that meanwhile on
Charles Evans Hughes the Chief Justice
is working behind the scenes to
discredit the plan particularly this
notion that the justices are behind in
their work so within days of the launch
of the court packing plan Hughes has the
leading political reporter for The
Washington Post who's a conservative it
was a conservative paper brings him into
his chambers and provides all sorts of
information that become a series of
front page articles that take apart this
notion point by point this notion that
the court is behind in its work and this
is damaging to the plan in its first
days and then really the the the most
damaging thing that Hughes did over the
course of the court fight is he allows
Brooke he lets it be known through
Brandeis that he might be willing to
testify against the plan in the Senate
that he might actually be willing to be
called as a witness
he actually was willing to be called as
a witness and sit there in the Senate
Judiciary Committee and attack the plan
Brandeis ultimately gets cold feet and
advises the chief not to do this but
they talk together about other ways to
undercut the plan and so what Hughes
does is right he writes an open letter
to - Bert wheeler who by this point has
become the leader of the Senate
opposition to the court plan and very
useful to the Conservatives because
here's a Democrat who has been with the
president a lot of things and he's
leading the opposition so Hughes writes
a letter to wheeler saying thank you for
asking me my views let me tell you what
I think and again using the same
information point by point devastates
the premises of the court plan and the
next day in the newspaper there's like
one of the newspapers there's a cartoon
with a with a big target and a
cannonball going through it and it says
bullseye the Hughes letter was was his
letter becomes a big and and what Hughes
does which again points to the political
sophistication of Charles Evans Hughes
who was no slouch compared to Roosevelt
he gets the agreement of two other
justices Brandeis on the left and Van
Deventer on the right and then suggests
that this came about so quickly that he
didn't have time to consult anybody but
clearly you can see that we speak for
the entire court which was not true at
all but it was done and it was very
effective does the plan ever officially
die at that point what what happens next
at that at that point well the plan has
a series of near-death experiences over
the course of six months sort of sort of
like the health care that's right
was a different ending right but I think
that it's very easy to look back and see
this as doomed
from day one and a lot of the previous
accounts of this sort of suggest that it
was doomed from the day that he that he
unleashed the plan and I think that's
not right I think one of the things
that's remarkable and speaks to not only
the the the enormous power that
Roosevelt had the the power of
persuasion that the Roosevelt had and
also to the strength of his argument
against the court during that period is
when he launches this plan and shocks
everybody and there's all this
opposition in the press and there's all
this opposition in the Congress if you
look at the Gallup polls its evenly
split and even though the numbers go up
1% 2% kind of back and forth and
ultimately the opponent's gain an edge
over the course of this the public
remains pretty evenly split throughout
this fight and it does seem that it
could kind of go either way and so there
are many opportunities over the course
of the six-month fight no matter what is
happening and we can talk about some of
the twists and turns where Roosevelt
might very well have gotten exactly what
he asked for and gotten six justices or
if he'd been willing to compromise as a
number of his advisers were urging him
to do he could have easily I think
gotten four justices or two and we'd
have a court of 11 or 13 today one name
you have not yet mentioned who is in
many respects the essential figure all
this is Justice Roberts why is he so
important well Owen Roberts is important
because it is owned Roberts who switches
in the middle of this fight as the bill
is debate being debated in in the Senate
Roberts votes to uphold a minimum wage
law that is virtually identical to one
that he voted down exactly one year
before and and this is sometimes called
the switch in time that saved the knot
that's right
and and but do you think what why did he
switch that that is a historically rich
question this is one of the great
mysteries of the period and there are a
lot of theories he burned his papers
before he died and he he never he never
talked openly about it although he did
imply a number of things which I'll get
to in a moment
Owen Roberts was an interesting guy he
was he was from Philadelphia he was an
industrious and brilliant guy who was
the son of a hardware merchant went to
the University of Pennsylvania and he
did so well there that as soon as he
graduated as a law student they hired
him immediately to teach the law he was
a brilliant advocate a Republican in a
very Republican City and he came to the
attention of President Coolidge and who
appointed him to investigate the Teapot
Dome scandal so the Harding
administration and he did a very
effective job at that he sent to the
Secretary of Interior Albert fall to
jail and was sort of celebrated for his
probity his ideology was an open
question and when he got appointed by
Hoover in 1930 to the Supreme Court he
had not been Hoover's first choice but
Hoover's previous choice had been shot
down by progressives in the Senate both
sides saw something to cheer about
conservatives looked at his record as a
Republican and some of the public
statements that he'd made they thought
he's with us and liberals thought well
look he prosecuted the Harding
administration and and he's not an
ideologue particularly and so both sides
cheered the appointment of Roberts and
actually his ideology his jurisprudence
remains something of a mystery even
within the court for years stone
couldn't figure him out
and he seemed to go back and forth
generally conservative but open-minded
in certain ways and it involved and
involved and even wrote some important
liberal opinions in the early 1930s but
in 1935 he throws his lot in with the
Conservatives and it's not simply that
he's voting with the Conservatives it's
that he's writing these incredibly
vehement almost school
full opinions they put him very much out
in front he writes the opinion on the
triple-a he writes the opinion on some
other things they are very strident in
sweeping opinions and so he seems
entirely lost so it's an amazing thing
when he finally switches back and that
is in 1937 that's right what is the
political impact of the Cour switching
to a more Pro deal new deal posture well
it's it's tremendous and I just want to
be sure that I that I finished the
thought on Roberts come back to your
original question which is why he switch
and he um he was very interested in
public opinion not all of them were to
that extent but he was more out in
Washington social and political circles
he really did seem more than the others
to care what people thought about him
and he was even he was so attractive in
many ways that he was even talked about
seriously as a presidential candidate to
run against Roosevelt in 1936 and he
seemed to like the attention
now when the Supreme Court began
striking everything down in this way and
he was as I said very much in the front
of that a lot of contempt really rained
down on him because he had flipped back
and forth before and so he was seen to
be responsible for this in the same way
that today most of it comes down on
Justice Kennedy you know the way that
Scalia's gonna vote most in most cases
but the question is Justice Kennedy so
when something goes the wrong way from
someone's perspective they tend to point
the finger at Kennedy and it was the
same with Roberts and he took this very
much to heart it was a very difficult
period for him and it seems that the the
public opinion that amassed against the
court and then the incredible
repudiation of conservatism in the 1936
landslide seemed to have a real effect
on Roberts
and he finds himself back in the camp
with Brandeis Cardozo stone and Hughes
and how just to finish the the narrative
how does the plan die officially well
many of Roosevelt's advisers as you
would imagine expect that now that
now that the court is switched and he's
getting the results that he saw it not
just in the minimum wage case which
wasn't technically a New Deal program
but then the Wagner Act the National
Labor Relations Act is upheld that the
first one was in March the second one
was in April and in May the Supreme
Court upholds Social Security which
everybody had thought was was doomed and
so throughout this period commentators
and even some of Roosevelt's advisors
are saying give up the fight wait to see
if roberts and hughes go back to the
other side you can always renew the
fight later Walker just compromise and
settle for two justices but here's the
main reason then he doesn't do that and
why he keeps fighting because well two
reasons one he doesn't believe for a
minute that he used in Roberts or in the
liberal camp to stay particularly
Roberts he's flipped before he's gonna
flip again and the second reason is that
it is an open secret in Washington that
Roosevelt years before had promised the
next Supreme Court seat to the Senate
Majority Leader Joe Robinson who was
this big bull of a man from Arkansas
who's had this dream this entire life to
be a Supreme Court justice and even
though he opposed most of the New Deal
he carried it through the Senate on his
shoulders and so Roosevelt offered this
to him and when Robinson promptly made
this known to everybody and so Roosevelt
understood that if he only got two seats
one of them was gonna have to be
Robinson who wasn't really a real
supporter of the New Deal and then the
other seat would be a liberal and they
would just cancel each other out so he
wouldn't really gain anything in terms
of the balance of power on the court so
so how it ends
so this drags have held for a while and
Roosevelt keeps fighting into the summer
and ultimately Robinson says to
Roosevelt
I've got enough votes I'm gonna push
this thing through we're gonna get it
done it's very least we're gonna get for
I might even be able to get six and as
Robinson is throwing himself bodily into
this fight yelling at people in the
galleries in the Senate and and back and
forth with wheeler on the floor it's
very sort of almost violent and this
in it not at all like today Robinson
collapses in the Senate turns purple and
is carried outside where he gets some
air and then goes home and the next
morning he's found dead on the floor of
his apartment and with Robinson dies any
hope that anything is going to get done
there's a chance to the very end that
that that Robinson is going to carry
this through and get at least four and
maybe six justices for the president but
with Robinson that chance goes away and
the opponents are able to kill the bill
but Roosevelt loses the battle and wins
the war because he I mean it's
interesting
one thing that George Bush Jimmy Carter
and Franklin Roosevelt have in common is
that george w bush is that they didn't
get any supreme court appointments in
their first terms jimmy carter only
served one so he's the only president in
American history not to have servants to
serve a full term and not make an
appointment to the court but when they
start coming to Roosevelt they come in a
rush they these appointments so who
leaves first and who gets appointed well
this is actually an interesting twist
that I that I didn't mention in the
story which is that in the middle of the
Supreme Court fight after the Supreme
Court is upheld the minimum wage law and
upheld the Wagner Act
Van Deventer announces his retirement
and this is another one of these the
series of devastating blows to the court
plan all of a sudden Roosevelt gets a
chance to appoint a justice and on Van
Deventer is one of the most conservative
members of the court this is a very
carefully timed retirement that he
worked out privately with wheeler and
and one other senator timed for maximum
effect and then a few days later the
court upholds Social Security so one by
one these the pegs are being knocked out
from under Roosevelt's argument so after
the the fight is finished right after
the fight is finished in October 1937
Roosevelt finally gets to a point is for
Supreme Court justice and he appoints
Hugo black and we all know that you go
black is I think well many people view
and was one of the great jurists of the
century or at least the second half of
this
entry but one of the things that drew
Roosevelt to Hugo black there were two
things really his loyalty to the New
Deal and also the feeling that this
would really stick it in the eye of the
Senate then black didn't out a lot of
friends in the Senate he was a tough
sort of investigator and he and
alienated a lot of fellow senators but
because of this tradition which might
still exist we'll see some day of
senatorial courtesy where any senator is
nominated the court sort of waved
through they knew they had to approve
black but they didn't like it and and
and that is followed by William O
Douglas Felix Frankfurter Wiley Rutledge
Roosevelt comes to have eight
appointments to the core he completely
transforms the court and is a Roosevelt
court very quickly and and remains such
for a generation and one of the things
that that the Roosevelt Court is known
for is allowing a very expansive
conception of federal power federal
legislative authority which apparently
includes health care reform but maybe
we'll see so step back for a second what
why should we care what what is the
great story it's fascinating but why is
it relevant today well I think it's it's
relevant for for a number of reasons and
first it raises the question of the
court is a political institution and
whether public opinion public pressure
political pressure exercises there
should exercise any influence on the
Supreme Court this is sort of an eternal
question in American public life and the
the court at this point had taken itself
very far outside of mainstream of
American thought and really was standing
in the way of what a vast majority of
Americans felt needed to be done it was
taking no judicial notice to use a term
of the court of economic realities and
so the court had allowed itself to fall
very much out of step and there was as
there has been periodically in America
history a sharp public counter-reaction
which had as it often does in American
history an effect on the court itself
and the decisions that the court made so
this is a question for us very much
right now well and let's let's address
that question
you see Barack Obama during the State of
the Union attacking the court for the
Citizens United case you see Justice
Alito saying not true and all of us
lip-reading from home
you see Chief Justice Roberts in his
speech in Alabama saying it was an
unseemly spectacle and maybe the
justices shouldn't go at all what what
what did you learn in writing supreme
power that informs how we should view
what's going on today well I think a
couple of things first I think that
President Obama needs to be careful that
he doesn't personalize this fight with
the Supreme Court I personally just
speaking for myself I think it was
entirely appropriate for him to
criticize that decision and to do so in
the State of the Union address he didn't
attack the justices he didn't attack the
conservative majority or the idea of
judicial power or anything like that he
said this decision is going to have
serious consequences and we're gonna try
to act to to correct those and III don't
think that we should assume that the
justices are so vulnerable that they
can't sit in a room and hear that we
don't worry too much about the
sensitivities of the members of Congress
I'm not sure why we should assume the
justices are so delicate especially when
they have life tenure and members of
Congress are down yeah that's right
that's right
but I I think that at the same so I
think it's entirely appropriate for a
president to criticize a Supreme Court
decision to criticize as many Supreme
Court decisions as he thinks need to be
remarked upon or corrected but I do
think that what the court packing
episode shows us is that there is
serious political danger for a president
in personalizing the conflict in the
court and having as it seemed a couple
weeks ago we might have a kind of
running back and forth between the White
House press office at the very least and
the Chief Justice and other justices not
only did we have Alito's reaction during
the State of the Union as you mentioned
and the Chief Justice's comment but
Clarence Thomas said something similar
inbetweening that didn't get as much
notice because we're sort of used to
glanced Thomas saying things like that
but not in court not in court that's
right
not since 2006 if he asked a question
yet but I think that what the court
packing episode also points up is that
there is real danger in the court as
well and I think that even though Chief
Justice Hughes was very effective when
he came out publicly in that way against
the court packing plan it did give
commentators a great opportunity to
paint him as a politician and there was
some real damage done to the court
during that period where it was where
the justices were were quite clearly
seen as political actors and if justice
alito justice thomas and particularly
Chief Justice Roberts are going to
continue to comment publicly in whatever
fashion on the other branches or the
propriety of what the other branches may
be saying or doing then I think that
there is a long-term cost to the
credibility of the court we don't
believe that they are purified by the
putting on of judicial rows we don't
believe that anymore but we want to
believe that and we don't like to think
of the justices as raw political actors
or just commenting as Mitch McConnell
might on what the other branches are
doing so I think there's a danger in it
for Chief Justice Roberts and for the
court as well let's move to questions we
have a gentleman with a microphone
go over here and we only ask that you
stand up when you speak and speak into
the microphone so our c-span viewers can
hear you and see you when that last
Supreme Court ruling came down about the
corporate giving I was very much enraged
and I thought I'm going to send a letter
off but then I thought I can't send this
to the Supreme Court because they're not
going to even bother with my opinion am
I correct in assuming that that's true
well I might defer to Jacqueline the
answer is there is nothing that stops
you from it will take once it will take
some time to get there because all of
their letters are checked for anthrax
after the anthrax scare and it's very
takes a very long time for the mail to
get there it varies a lot Harry Blackmun
his papers are in the Library of
Congress and he kept all the mail about
Rovi way he became deeply obsessed and
personalized his identification with
that and he kept all the hate mail and
he kept all the the mail that was
favorable to him and he read it all
intently several of the justices I would
say a majority don't read those kind of
letters at all but you as a citizen are
more than able to write a letter and all
you need is the zip code 205 for three
and it'll get there no problem
next question haven't way in the back
there
hi recently in the past years I've
noticed people saying that justices
won't retire because they want to keep
their own political views maybe or their
own desires in check why would all these
conservative justices decide to leave
the court at such a crucial time when
they were so opposed just weeks months
years before wow what a great question
that's a very good question
they decided that the gig was up that it
was over there Roberts was not coming
back even though Roosevelt out doubted
that they had been in conferences and
the judicial conferences and they had a
very strong sense which they shared with
one another that it was over that
Roberts wasn't coming back
Hughes who had gone back and forth a
little bit wasn't wasn't coming back and
that there was really no point in
staying on the court so one by one
particularly the older justices who had
had some health problems left and the
last holdout among the Conservatives was
as you might expect from our description
McReynolds who famously said at the time
and I will edit this comment that he
would not leave the court as long as
that crippled SOB was still in the White
House ultimately Roosevelt by being
reelected a third time outlasted
McReynolds and McReynolds finally
retired and then of course Roosevelt was
reelected again but there was the
feeling that it was a lost cause at
least for a generation and they were
right about that
yes sir a number of states have sued to
reverse the health plan and I wonder why
the plan was rather controversial as you
remember and you know they're 13
Republican attorneys general have have
sued the definition of a state attorney
general is someone who is running for
governor this is a politically
advantageous move on their part you know
there is now a great deal of commentary
including some by me in the web and
elsewhere about whether these lawsuits
have any chance of succeeding I think
the answer by and large is no certainly
just to cite a legal doctrine there is a
doctrine called ripeness which says that
the courts don't address controversies
until the controversy is joined the
legally that the thing that is most
challenged in in in these lawsuits is
the so called individual mandate the
requirement that people buy health
insurance that doesn't even kick in
until 2014 so I don't think most courts
would even address a challenge till
people are actually required to buy
health insurance so I think it's for the
most part political theater not that
there's anything wrong with political
theater let's can we go over here so I
don't mean to how about all the way back
there just that gentleman there okay
thank you what did you hear your
comments about the Schechter NRA
decision and also Brandeis as role in
that the sick chicken case sick chicken
case well this checked er case is the
case that killed the NRA in 1935 and
there was some trepidation within the
administration about going forward with
this case but they didn't really have
very many good options this was not a
great test of the NRA and there was also
as I suggested earlier a lot of
ambivalence within the administration
about the NRA by that point and the
question of whether it should be
reauthorized in what form so it all came
to rest
in this case about a kosher chicken
plant in Brooklyn now kosher chickens
many of us implies a certain kind of
purity this was very far from the case
in 1935 the industry was notorious for
selling diseased contaminated birds that
have this sort of rabbinical blessing on
them and they seemed to be very clean
and so there was as in most industries
and this is what the NRA was about there
were codes that were agreed to by the
leaders in the industry and signed by
the president by which they agreed to
impose a minimum wage to impose caps on
the number of hours to improve working
conditions and any one of a number of
other things and so the Schechter
brothers these four brothers in Brooklyn
were charged with violating the live
poultry code on a number of counts and
they were found guilty and this found
its way out all the way to the Supreme
Court now this was as they suspected in
the administration this was a very
unfortunate case to go to the Supreme
Court and this is the the one New Deal
case where it went not 5-4 against the
administration but nine to nothing
against the administration and even
Cardozo said his famous line from from
the period is that this was delegation
run riot they found this
unconstitutional partly on the grounds
of excessive delegation of power from
the Congress to extra legislative
entities like these code authorities and
so this was a even though Roosevelt on a
certain level was happy to see the NRA
go he didn't want it to go in this
fashion and the it was a moment of real
drama it was a day that became known as
Black Monday because there were a couple
of other decisions that went against the
administration nothing right after the
then new Supreme Court building open
that's right the would be building that
we are now you know so what just did
associated with the Supreme Court just
opened in time for that confrontation
this is for in the previous hundred
years the Supreme Court had been in
cramped quarters across the street in
the Capitol but I what I think the
Schechter poultry is so interesting is
you know and this also has to do with
you know FDR's extraordinary luck in
addition to everything else know the
they kill the NRA which was basically a
failure anyway but they keep Social
Security NLRB so you know they almost
didn't him a favor in that work well and
there was some talk in the in the
country that they had done him a favor
on the NRA but I I think that it's
something I probably should have pointed
out earlier this question of why
Roosevelt would not wait we've talked
many times about how old the justices
were and and you raised this the the
matter of this incredible succession of
appointments that Roosevelt got in the
end why didn't he just wait
particularly if some of these decisions
he didn't necessarily object to in a
political sense like the NRA decision
and I think that it's important to put
yourself back in the moment which is
something that I try to do in the book
there was a very real sense in the
country and Roosevelt shared it that if
they couldn't get some of these things
through the court not simply the
programs but the very notion of a
governmental obligation to provide
Economic Security for citizens if you
couldn't get minimum wages through the
court if you couldn't get maximum hours
if you couldn't improve working
conditions if you couldn't recognize
labor rights the right of collective
bargaining the right simple right to
organize that there would be violent
revolution in the country and this was
not a far-fetched notion in the 1930s at
the beginning of 1937 you have a wave of
sit-down strikes across the country that
become very violent and there is the
sense that if the Wagner Act is struck
down there is going to be something
approaching a revolution one commentator
said that when the court reaches its
decision on the Wagner Act on the
the National Labor Relations Act that
they would write the decision either in
blood or an ink and they opted for ink
and and we just want the real revelation
to me of reading supreme power was you
know I I was of course aware of the
court packing crisis but I'd never read
a whole book about it and I always kind
of assumed that it was this sort of mad
power grab by FDR it you know who was
drunk on power after winning this
tremendous reelection and yes there's
that element but your portrait of FDR
you at least understand why he did it
that it was not an entirely irrational
act and I think that's a tremendous
contribution to understanding of the
period but I'm sorry I don't want to
talk about I want it just a couple more
questions before we go about this
gentleman in the back words they're
going to I'm sorry to be sending you
right just a couple deny professorship
so you said that before 1935 they're
been decades of a court being
conservative before Roosevelt actually
got his eight picks was there any time
the court was not conservative well
first I should just correct the record
I'm not actually a professor I just play
one on TV on c-span tonight there yeah
I'm not one either but you can call me
professor senator I'll answer to that
the truth is call you a lot of misbehave
there is not a great shining liberal
period for the court between about the
1880s and and this moment when the court
switches there are certainly some
important liberal decisions particularly
as I suggested in the area of civil
liberties and the court had actually
taken over this period of well in in the
in the teens and 20s a kind of a mixed
view of state experiments with social
and economic legislation there weren't
really very many federal experiments
until Roosevelt got in the federal
government under Harding and Coolidge
and Hoover generally didn't think that
the federal government should be in the
business of passing social or economic
form so most of it was being done by the
states and the court tended to take kind
of a mixed view and there are swings in
the court and you hear you're a little
kind sometimes described as the Lochner
era after a case from 1905 where new
york state passed a law that said there
was a maximum number of hours bakers
could work and thus the court struck
that down is a violation of the right to
contract of these poor slob immigrant
bakers and you know i mean the the court
as an engine of you know uncontrolled
capitalism I mean that's certainly my no
I I think I think on the whole that's
absolutely right and then in eighteen
nineteen eighteen you have a hammer
decision which overturns a federal ban
on child labor to such an extent that it
seems that the only solution is to ban
child labor by a constitutional
amendment which is an effort that picks
up steam and then sort of dies away they
can't pass up one more men men against
question from this gentleman here
oh wait wait for the microphone
I was in college in 1937 and to round
out what you said and I'm still here and
to round out what you said there wasn't
just Roosevelt there was Huey Long it
was father Coughlin there was Townsend
there were all kinds of nuts running
around and with with political theories
and Roosevelt had to take that into
consideration why I think you for that
comment that's absolutely right the
stakes were the survival of democracy as
Roosevelt put it as I said earlier he
saw no contradiction between the
Constitution and the New Deal
and he felt that the very survival
democracy depended on getting some of
these social and economic reforms
through now as he said we could not wait
for the justices to retire so he arrived
at a plan that may seem to us to be
radical but to something that you raised
a moment ago he actually felt that
considering all the alternatives and I
talked a little bit earlier about the
constitutional amendments which were
very radical in in their unbalancing of
the the system of checks and balances
that actually the most moderate and
prudent and reasonable thing to do would
be to pack the court it was clearly
constitutional it had been done many
times in the 19th century it would solve
the problem immediately he would pick
justices carefully and it did not do
damage as I said earlier to the fabric
of the Constitution he really didn't
want to tinker with the Constitution
because he didn't think that there was
anything wrong with it and so I think
that it's very easy to say this was a
rash act and act of hubris we can say
that it was the wrong thing to do we
might disagree with what Roosevelt chose
to do but he arrived at this decision is
Jeff indicated after a lot of debate and
discussion with his advisors over a
number of years where they carefully
considered just about every option Under
the Sun they looked at what had been
done in the United Kingdom they looked
around the world
that other acts of judicial reform and
what could possibly be done in this case
so it was a very thorough examination
he spent the entirety of his first term
doing it and then he arrived at this
decision so it was neither rash nor
impulsive it may or may not have been
wise depending on the view that you take
of it but it was not an irrational act
it was so long ago
am i right Fox News was just on the
radio building could we get one more
Mike I see we just hang on wait for the
microphone
William vanden Heuvel great Jeff that's
a brilliant narrative you've told and I
appreciate it
I would say the one justice who was
rarely mentioned is Harlan Fiske stone
who was also a member of that Court and
who was appointment by Roosevelt as
Chief Justice in 1941 seems to me to
indicate Roosevelt's great respect for
the court stone was a conservative
appointed by Calvin Coolidge and he
himself was critical within
deliberations of the court regarding
what had gone on my question really is
about democracy the Supreme Court is an
undemocratic institution its members are
appointed for life and they're
accountable to no one and the exercise
of power that can cancel out what the
vast majority of Americans say they want
in a congressional legislation or
however isn't it our obligation to ask
questions about our court and to
criticize it and to insist that it be
opened up as gary has opened it up in
his brilliant books instead of
pretending that this is a group of nine
people who operate objectively and who
have only the best interest of the
nation at heart let them defend that
Federal Election Commission decision and
let the Congress be part
well first I just want to thank
ambassador vanden Heuvel for being here
there is no one I know who has done more
to preserve the legacy of Franklin
Roosevelt ambassador Daniel thank you
sir
and and my short answer to your question
is yes I think the court should be
criticized and I think that its
decisions should be questioned and while
they are unaccountable in an electoral
sense this is the way that courts are
held accountable by a constant public
discussion of what the court is doing
and a constant public discussion of the
stakes at one point over the course of
this long fight as you know Felix
Frankfurter advises Franklin Roosevelt
to take the country to school he wanted
to educate the public about the court
about its power and the effects of its
decisions and that that's something that
Roosevelt very much took to heart and I
think it's something that really every
president should take to heart and I
want to be clear I wasn't implying the
President Obama shouldn't engage in a
similar sort of discussion I do think
that it's important that his staff
members don't see this as the kind of
out-and-out political brawl that they
have with John Boehner or Mitch
McConnell this is a different thing and
they need to proceed with caution but
they should be true to what they believe
and they should call attention to what
the court is doing absolutely supreme
power is for sale at the bookstore
I encourage everyone to buy it and I
thank you all and thank
[Music]
for more information visit West Wing
riders org